[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to a
special 420 edition of honest trailer
commentaries that's right it's two days
before earth day we're celebrating early
i'm here with lon harris i'm here with
daniel radford
what are your guys's earth day plans
before we get into the show
i planted things i planted a lavender
thing oh lavender
yeah and i've got some uh uh uh oh one
of those plants we grow in california
because we ain't got water
i've got a bunch of those succulent
succulents yeah you gotta spray them
puppies down you don't have to do
anything i am into i am gonna i'm gonna
become a plant influencer that's my new
thing
wow is there a short is there a plant
fluency is there a
is there yeah yeah like whatever daddies
yeah oh plant daddies there you go uh
it's tree day
i'm a brother
um yeah i will be uh uh uh smoking some
synchronic that i found at a drug store
earlier
i'll let you know how that goes it's a
wild trip
did you like it so high you think you're
a caveman i won't spoil it but i love
that whenever you think time travel in
movies it's always
like wild west like maybe like
renaissance or like shakespeare times
it's never just like the 20 000
years where we were just like messed up
more than that yeah
like screaming you know like it's 200
000 years worth of uh cave times before
anything interesting happened where it's
just like
some vile evil hominid like coming at
you like that's
almost all history as far as i will say
a period of time
perhaps uh two days before earth day
um ancient aliens hmm you be the judge
we
i'm not saying it's aliens guys but
anyways we're here to talk about our uh
double feature today for reefer madness
and big lebowski we're gonna watch the
trailer together
uh we're gonna show you some cut scenes
and jokes maybe a little outtakes
um you'll be surprised who is making the
chewing noises
and then we'll respond to uh comments
and questions from viewers like yourself
so keep those coming in the chat
uh hopefully some will be in the script
but if not i will go
look i'll get in i'll wade into that
chat with you guys and see see what
you're saying um
so yeah we uh we i think for the first
time in australia's history tuesday has
fallen on a 420 so
we felt like uh it'd be fun to do
something appropriate
there aren't that many like there's a
lot of popular weed movies but there
isn't
one that's like far and away like i
think we all have our favorites i
i prefer half baked um what what do you
guys like in this genre maybe a
pineapple express or something
have baked as my friend friday friday is
a friday we've already done friday but
yeah
half fake friday sort of the modern
classics i think like up and smoke the
the classic cheech
chong adventure i also the timing was
right for how high
to be a movie that i enjoyed when it was
when it was new
um you know but yeah i think i think
those are those are sort of that
our generations kind of yeah and it
turns out that like
the the few gems we we pointed out i
think that
weed content is bad for the most part
like stuff that's just overtly about it
is not good or fun
like whether it's a movie or someone's
personality it's
it's not there's not much there but i do
think that things
can be enjoyed more like the big
lebowski that just has kind of this
otherworldly
vibe and he he does smoke like four
joints throughout the thing so
i thought that's one i don't think we've
ever done coen brothers so
i really wanted to take it hard because
there's a self-awareness
to the coen brothers that makes it hard
to parody because it's kind of already
a joke a meta joke about what it's doing
so
yeah i think there's a reason we haven't
maybe dove into the code brothers yet
i've never seen reefer madness until
this last week
um i just had seen that the faster
faster clips
for playing the piano and man this was
this was terrible
have you seen reefer madness before and
what'd you guys think i did because i
like bad movies
famous like everybody knows that if you
know me i really like bad movies but
this one doesn't fit the criteria of a
good bad movie
it's just kind of the first movie
someone wrote like
this was this was this dude's first
movie and it was to scare the children
from the marijuana um so
yeah it's not a fun watch um
it's a little tedious for me it's super
tedious it really feels like a
very boring thriller like a
noir like good kids get in over their
head like it feels like that
and then the the marijuana stuff is
inserted it like it doesn't even feel
like it organically is part of the movie
the movie's like this courtroom thing
and it's like you know like the you know
like oh we're caught in this you know
we're now trapped
we got to get out of it all that stuff
um so yeah it's
it's very clunky and i don't feel like i
feel like it would need to be a little
more realistic
to scare you off of smoking pot
yeah i mean it's so outlandish that
you're like well this isn't scary
because it's so obviously fake
yeah it's it's propaganda i mean in in a
very
in a very real sense it's like what's
his anslinger henry or
harry anslinger and william randolph
hearst were like i don't like
latinos how can we get rid of them let's
demonize the marijuana so we can
we can lock them up and they produce
like his papers
and then this whole pr push the war on
drugs kind of began in the 30s
um back before then you could get your
cocaine
uh over the counter and everything was
great yeah
it was perfect the way things ought to
be right
i'll take cocaine and a root beer please
it's like harold you could like buy
heroin at the store like hmm got a
little bit
well let's call my little company but
somehow marijuana got lumped in
uh became a schedule one controlled
substance and the rest is history uh
thanks to movies like this um so that's
a bummer
uh uh but i did they did use this movie
screenings of this movie to fundraise
for the the legalization movement which
i found
ironic um that you would pay to see this
movie to help fight
uh the thing it was created to uh to
prevent so
i guess there's a streisand effect thing
i think to a lot of that
like a lot of the anti-drug stuff ends
up
fueling people's desire to try drugs
i think and this is this is like a prime
example of it makes it seem fun because
it's
this is such a ridiculous like in the
other direction
yeah and it almost it almost you know
yeah cuts well with that said let's
let's launch into
reefer madness big lebowski we'll have
we'll have more to say as
as it progresses we had to fake all
these requests by the way
pause for some easter eggs so when you
when you want to see who's asking for it
okay i'm ready what are we doing this
week an old black and white movie
is this hitchcock or something oh reefer
madness
nice my hair's pretty funny hold on let
me grab my chips
all right hit it hell y'all chill
you're ready for a bunch of
one sec get ready for a movie that's
supposed to scare young people off pot
by lying about how bad it is for 90
minutes straight
and they still showing you the effective
pot
like every single joint in this movie is
laced with pcp
because they like go pedal to the metal
like when they're driving like i'm on
pun
they're like speeding around corners
they're dancing like as fast as they
possibly can and like
speeding up the music and like fighting
and shooting each other
which in my uh personal experience means
that you've just smoked angel dust
[Laughter]
yeah it's it's like it's like pot is all
drugs like they're just like they have
one category and it's like this is what
happens when you do drugs it's what
happens if you do literally any drug
it's like
caffeine heroin cocaine pot like it's
all drugs at once
you can't there's no yeah there's no
yeah all of them
all of them make you like one step away
from being naked on the laundromat on
cops
yeah it's all like psychosis they like
blackout like they don't remember
it's like that doesn't that doesn't
happen you can totally remember
anyways keep going how it's cheap pieces
it goes wild in almost every state in
the union and will basically get you
laid on the spot
man i wish they were true in real life
way to make pod look even better movie
return to this that that part that's
crazy like there's a thing in this movie
there's a whole scene where
the the like the guy who hates pot goes
to like the fbi and he's like why don't
you guys just make
just shut down pot nationwide and he's
like well we can't
because it just grows wild all over the
country and people could just pick it
and get stoned if there's something we
could do
that is not true that's never been true
anybody who's
sort of true it says no it's a weed it's
right there in the name
there there is like there are marijuana
plants that sometimes will grow
wild and it's only because people
planted them at one point in history but
uh it that's that's like hemp that's not
you can't just pick it
anybody who's tried to grow smokeable
cannabis will tell you you gotta try
it's not just like gonna happen
overnight for no reason yeah if you're
like a like a connoisseur but there's
definitely like you could
you if you walk through a temperate area
like uh
say the the california bay area and just
scattered seeds into the woods and came
back like
after after the rainy season you could
probably get a joint
johnny potted seed now you're arguing
yes if you planted
pot it would grow nobody's arguing that
it's a plant i'm saying it doesn't
happen wildly on its own all across the
country where you could just be walking
down the road be like
look at that i'm gonna pick me an eighth
like that's not what but
well it's more so like you can't tell
people that in your movie that's not we
all know that's not true
it is sort of true it's more so than
cocaine or heroin or something where you
have to refine it you have to do
something to it like
it's a plant you just pick the bud
if if you've already planted it yeah
well sure i've walked for uh i've walked
all across this country
looking for wild marine caves
uh okay keep going when every kid in
high school
looked like they were in their 30s and
even potheads wore a full suit and tie
as you're introduced to eddie well hello
gwen
it's all right gwen ralph oh hello kenny
teddy teddy mary jimmy
jimmy jack perry jack perry bill
bledge and hot fingers pirelli
yeah there's no way i'm keeping all
these mayo ass names straight what's the
main dork's name again
bill bill okay bill i don't know
i i you can tell this is like somebody's
first movie or something like that
because they're like well we need to
introduce all the characters for the
rest of the play
oh we need to meet them all because all
those intros are in maybe
packed within maybe a minute and a half
or two minutes and
it's just like how will how will we know
that these people haven't met before
unless we see them all meeting for the
first time
so it's also weird like the implication
is they all know it
like they've all it's a neighborhood
like they all won't go to school
together
grew up together there's so many ways
you could just do that with shorthand
like they're all in the
soda jerk together having a whatever a
lime ricky or they're all
they're all at school or like some but
they don't
there's like 18 individual scenes where
like groups of two
or three of them meet up and it's like
efficiency of storytelling man
what is a what is a lime ricky oh a lime
ricky is a
thing you'd have down at the the soda
jerk i don't know
like a chocolate phosphate it would be
yeah it would be like uh
i'm assuming that era's version of like
a sprite or a 7up type
drink but made custom for you rather
than from a bottle
that looks delicious i might have myself
a nice lime ricky a nice lime ricky i'm
not i'm not making it oh it looks like a
cocktail
maybe i'm wrong yeah don't put a suit on
if you drink it cause i'm not gonna know
who you are
in like olden times i think there was a
there was a
virgin version of the lime ricky i'm
pretty sure you would order it like
it didn't necessarily have gin or
bourbon in it but you can apparently
make it that way yeah if i was wearing a
suit and holding a lime ricky you
wouldn't know whether to call me
spencer will bill tim ken uh
or no top fingers gilbert
finger spenny that's it yeah
naturally
[Laughter]
follow along with bill a loser who's
hopeless with girls and bullied by
children
who develops a condition where he can't
stop laughing
until he finally snaps and shoots
somebody
so it's like the exact same plot as
joker joker's tough
experience a film that was scandalous
for its time because a girl rolls down
her stockings or whatever
but is mostly just boring really really
boring
you can tell that this was like trying
to serve two audiences like
or maybe the same audience of like the
repressed
parent i think cause like they're
showing you like you go you go watch the
movie and it shows you how bad marijuana
is and how it's corrupting your children
but like you're going to watch
the marijuana corrupt the children and
see like women of ill repute roll down
their lacy stockings at night
oh oh bother um i feel like it's
it's trying to like i mean it's trying
to make money like they're trying to get
you to
watch something like scandalous while
then telling you how bad everything is
yeah it's just you know uh in any era
sex sells or whatever that was because
that's not that's just
that's just putting on clothes um but in
any era that's what works i guess get
the butts and seeds
yeah i mean in some ways this is like
the proto version of like the after
school special so they're trying to use
the language of the kinds of things
you'd already watch
to tell you some awful message yeah it's
like
sneak subterfuge you know yeah but you
see a lady's ankle and then like
you catch the vapors you have to and she
auditioned for that that was
i'm sorry about it i think about like
real people auditioned to be in this
movie god bless them
you will there if you do get this role
there will be some
ankle nudity required put it right in
your
we'll have a sensitivity consultant on
the set when
ankles are revealed and everybody will
be just be you and the director
so you'll be wearing a sleeve an ankle
if you're wearing an ankle sleeve no
actual
contact i want to see like hbo when
you're watching something good and it
has like the bn
like brief nudity violence or whatever
that for for reefer madness or it'd be
like
uh fp like fast piano playing
ba brief ankle yeah ankle revealed
all right keep going really boring as
you sit through the most depressing
opening crawl
since ryza skywalker sit through
marathon pta meetings
and sit through a slow courtroom drama
that would make any teenager want to
jump out a window
actually you know what can we just bail
on this one early whole film's a huge
bummer
half of it is just boring and the other
half is just freaks playing piano
laughing at each other
everyone knew how to play piano back
then yeah every single person
and it was hilarious yeah the connection
to
like specifically
and the piano is like
can we watch something else that's what
i'm talking about
now where did i leave benedict
cumberbatch oh there you are
i feel like that's what his bomb would
be named epic voice guy the character
okay much better spark a j
pour yourself a white russian and relax
for the most chilled out la detective
story since the long goodbye
oregon's way you know night moves was
pretty great oh then there's devil in a
blue dress
and you've seen inherent vice right i
guess faded la detective noir is like a
whole genre huh
wait what movie was i talking about
again come on man
right the big lebowski
yeah fuzz film i mean i think that's
that that's no mistake like
la's the or at least has been the center
of
movie making and a lot of people do
drugs out here so you're going to end up
with a lot of movies of like
what if you had a guy kind of wandering
around baked trying to solve a crime
it's
yeah i mean a lot of it is like the
philip marlow
tradition i mean there's one of the
classic detective characters is this
very like
west coast detective and that's who
elliot is playing in long goodbye
it's who uh you know humphrey bogart
sort of memorably played philip marlow
uh uh the big sleep i believe is that
film and so uh
that's uh you know like i feel like it's
it's a tradition that's now just become
yeah this whole like
under the silver lake did you guys see
that yeah yeah an example of the like
sort of out of it trying to piece things
together but it's way too complicated
l.a noir story i gotta revisit uh
inherent vice
i didn't like it but i only saw it once
and i feel like i need to give that like
kind of let it wash over you the way
yeah the way these movies do i love it i
get that it's not for everybody
i'm not trying to like like i totally
get it's not like a talk down if you
didn't like get it or whatever like i
understand but yeah i think the key to
that movie is stop
trying to solve the mystery just like
it's super baffling
he does doc sportello doesn't get it
either just
appreciate what you're seeing and don't
try to piece it all together
yeah and i i definitely feel that way
about big lebowski like
i i've seen this a dozen times and like
i couldn't tell you like
where does the money end up at the end
i'm not sure i don't think it
particularly matters
um because it's just fun if you wanted
to i could unpack
what happens in big lebowski so it's not
very
at the very end i guess there never was
a million dollars in the first place no
you threw out a ringer for a forever
yeah okay uh all right well he no longer
digs bunny it was uh they were trying to
blackmail him but
david the big lebowski was like happy to
be rid of her
yeah yeah all right keep going mystery
solved
ever you know this movie even if you've
never
seen this movie you know it yeah well
you know that's just like uh your
opinion man
you even know the tv edit see what
happens when you find a stranger in the
alps
it's like pop culture hurt immunity the
film's crossed over into the shared
cosmic unconsciousness
boy i'm flying oh get ahold of yourself
every voice guy
but for real this film is such a cult
hit their entire fan conventions
this poster was on half the dorm rooms
in america and there's a lebowski
challenge where you drink a white
russian
every time the hero does which i do not
recommend because i mean
wow that's a lot of dairy yeah pause
um terrible idea uh and i love white
russians
um but eight in a in a two-hour span is
about
six too many how are you asking for it
at that point
uh have you ever tried but he he does it
in the movie and i've never
been bold enough just uh a creamer like
a dairy creamer white russian
where you don't have to just put the
dairy creamer in there wait what do you
do
you know like instead of coffee you'd
use the non-dairy creamer like the
powder
there's a scene in this movie where he
makes a white russian with that instead
so instead of like
kahlua you do instead of milk it's like
the milky way
right okay the just like in the little
you didn't
it no it's like it's a powder right it's
like non-dairy creamer it's like yeah
it's like that
it's yeah that's that's gross i'd rather
i'd rather not
i've never tried it yeah i'm okay i'm
okay with myself
i know where i came from
never forget um but yeah i think i i
i think half and half kahlua and uh and
a nice vodka and like
you're fine but it's just it's not the
kind of drink you want to like
session exactly it's a sipping and
hanging drink
it's not a competition drink yeah
exactly it's almost like a dessert i
really oh
before this movie especially i would
have thought of it as like exclusively a
dessert
drink it's like you have one maybe two
at the end of like the meal
and then you're you're not drinking
kahlua all night that's crazy
it's turning my stomach let's keep going
hurry
right along with the dude he's less of a
character
than a way of life jeff bridges cruises
his way through a plot that needs a flow
chart to follow
until you and he both stopped trying to
put the clues together and just enjoy
the ride
this is a very complicated case mod you
know a lot of ends a lot of outs a lot
of what have you
in a comedy that you don't really get
until you've seen it like three or four
times
it doesn't have jokes per se but just
weird characters repeating themselves
into the humor cracks your brain open
sometimes there's a man yeah pause uh
danielle you flagged this
and it's like oh wow they are constantly
repeating themselves
oh yeah yeah entire movie it's a good
rhythm like i get for the rhythm of the
movie why it works but the first couple
of times i was like do they even
i wonder if that's like a conscious
choice or if it's just a rhythm thing
you know
yeah uh yeah i i mean i i think i
definitely think it is a conscious
choice and i think part of it is like
it's how his it's how the dude's brain
works like there's the part where he
sees george w
h bush on tv like this aggression will
not stand and then that's
that's what comes to his mind later when
he's telling the guy i was like
this aggression will not stand man and i
think like that's
it's like this is how he's constantly
taking all of these things in but he's
not
it's not clear where any of the stuff
came from it's all just getting
repurposed
and i mean isn't that true of the of the
coen brothers in general where they are
this kind of like hodgepodge of
genre and and character traits and stuff
like that and like
i couldn't really tell you what the
point is except that like
life is meaningless but it's fun but
it's also fun
uh yeah it's just to hang out with some
cool people and then there's a story
that i guess you can or cannot pay
attention to but it's mostly
like look at all yeah like this movie
totally this movie lou and davis
burn after reading uh well a serious man
is very much like what you were saying
like it's all
we're all we're we're stuck in these
like repetitive kind of cycles
and there's you know like it's all this
search for meaning that's not
really there and there's like the upbeat
you know versions of that and then the
downbeat but uh
they're always kind of around that i
mean to what danielle was saying like
repetition is a huge thing in all
cohen brothers series like their humor
always plays around with
you know like uh hudsucker proxy with
like you know for kids or
you think he's wise he don't look wise
you know like it's always
you know or there's another one in that
one too do you know him
he went to school with you do you know
him
uh yeah they're awesome we should do a
coen brothers
like every cohen yeah every cone
brothers move but i think it's a lot
probably more popular on on this side of
the camera than the audience but
whatever so people like fargo
yeah all right keep going there's a man
sometimes there's a man where's the
money lebowski
where's the money lebowski see what
happens lebowski you see what happens
stay out of malibu lebowski stay out of
malibu
dead feet strong men also cry
strong run also her life is more
her life is in your hands dude they're
gonna kill that poor woman
they're gonna kill that poor woman he's
a good man
and thorough please see him jeffrey he's
and thorough they did not receive the
money you nitwit they did not receive
the money he believes in nothing he
believes in nothing
nothing is this your homework larry is
this your homework
you see what happens larry you see what
happens larry
um john did not have uh chips during the
recording session so
you're hearing a hybrid performance of
me
eating into a microphone
and uh and john bailey so i think i
deserve this partial voice-over credit
for this one for
you yeah you got to start an asmr
channel with that
now the interesting thing is i tried a a
lighter chip that didn't really have the
same presence and i switched to
a um uh trader joe's uh
non-cracker uh which had like a more of
a thickness than a chip and it came
through really well i think at the final
cut
it was sort of half on his trailer half
mukbang
yeah oh god
all right keep going but the dude
doesn't roll alone hit the lanes with
walter
who is extremely loud and wrong before
the internet made it fashionable
if he's not ranting about the war in
vietnam he's finding ways to make
everyone else's life harder
especially donnie's shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ]
up shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up
donny
and they'll all cross paths with a who's
who of that guy's
that girls and the late great psh
in this wishful film and fantasies for
aging i mean that's what makes the movie
is just
the amazing actors playing weird little
side characters that he's just
ping-ponging from
one to the next like i would watch any
of them
i would watch spin-offs of any of them
but as i say that the jesus spin-off
not great so i take i'll watch any of
them with the coen brother's full
involvement and um yeah or a noah holly
or something taking
uh taking the reins so yeah it's just
like uh
i don't know like that's that's the joy
in this movie and what makes it so
rewatchable is like the little
ticks and little snippets of dialogue
from all these people who could carry a
movie by themselves
uh just getting like a scene or two to
to do their thing
yeah yeah there's always such a specific
sense of
of place and of setting in almost every
code brothers movie where that's that's
really what they do is
it's less like a narrative driving
momentum story and it's more like this
is a world that extends way beyond the
parameters of the movie like fargo
obviously is another example like
you really feel like you're getting to
know this whole world and this is just
one thing that's happening and it's why
like fargo makes for such a cool tv show
because you can just keep
expanding out into that world and it's
got all these other
different corners like what was
happening in kansas city at that time
you know
it's a and i think that's yeah that's
what they do so well as they they build
these
weird mini little alternate realities
yeah i want to see uh uh barton fink
what's in the other rooms
let's let's go to the other floor this
week on barton
yeah but it's true like barton fix la or
the miller's crossing
you know like that setting like they're
all these like platforms
for these huge ensembles and these crazy
sprawling stories and it does feel like
yeah you could you could set five more
movies in the hollywood of barton fink
for sure
but when are they gonna do a marvel
movie
[Laughter]
just turned into jiminy glick
very excited for their take on multiple
man yeah
keep going in this wishful film and
fantasy for aging men
who dream of bowling all day in their
pjs then getting paid a lot of money to
smoke weed
and have responsibility-free sex with a
woman who doesn't care about how gross
your apartment is
living the dream dude so watch the coen
brothers and roger deakins team up for a
visual delight
that feels like it exists outside of
time because even though it's set in the
90s
and the villains are totally 80s
fighting characters who were stuck in
the 60s and 70s who are trapped in a
film noir caper straight out of the 40s
and 50s
it still somehow makes perfect sense
like there's something at the center of
it all that just kind of
ties the whole thing together you know
whoa
pause he never does get his rug back
though huh
he gets a different rug he steals a rug
from the big lebowski
as a replacement yeah but he tells brett
the old man says i can take any rug in
there
takes it back oh right yeah mod does
take that rug
so he ends it ruggles man damn
that sucks that's a shame
let's get a sequel going where he gets
his rug back um
yeah anyways keep going there's a little
lebowski on the way
that's true strikes the gutters ups and
downs
daring the fabulous big boy
forrest grump shut the [ __ ] up
a one a to who a three
pumpkin spice hoffman they called me by
your name
urbane cowboy ares god of war
but wait there's julianne moore oh hey
it's amy mann and flip flop a triple
dipper whip whip skateboard
pause high crime i don't want to jump
through that
syllable
he's not a chili peppers fan god bless
him um
but i was like you know like 90s rock
references and he's just there was cake
a few weeks ago
now yeah he was not he was he was out of
it for that that
uh time frame so i had to be like you
know like whip whip flip for flipping
apples
california speech now yeah
um like that that john daly one yeah
they made a fake uh chili pepper peppers
yeah um chili peppers music much like
flea it just like
shows up i don't know how you could
avoid it just shows up places yeah
that's what i mean like maybe you
wouldn't know that's who you're hearing
but i don't understand like if you were
just like you know the
the under the bridge song how's it going
the last 20 years it's yeah i've heard
it the modern equivalent
is like tyler perry just showing up and
stuff yeah
i'm excited for you know 20 years from
now i guess it's already classic rock
but when it's like really in the distant
past and like the futures
james gunn is making some like enormous
blockbuster
uh marvel movie and they make like an
awesome mix volume nine
and it's like chili peppers and jane's
addiction
all this stuff that was toad the wet
sprocket toad the wet
sprocket um i mean that stuff is
already like old like that's already
classic rock that's 30 years old like
that's as old
as you know like the 60s was when we
were listening to that music
yeah yeah terrifying it's sending me on
this whole
i was just random tangent but that's
what today's all about
is i was at the dentist yesterday and uh
they played two of the songs from
guardians of the galaxy in the dentist
office
i can't believe people think this the
soundtrack is good and cool
for for guardians of the galaxy like it
is seriously
waiting room music anyways
anyways heavy dad rock
listen i think i think it would like if
they weren't such like radio
like you've heard them so many times
sure
they would have more of an impact but
it's like you know they're they're all
okay also switching gears why does the
dude
like credence but not the eagles
like that seems very much in the same in
the same boat to me
no i think the the eagles even even in
its arrow was like
it's like soft they're the polished
flakes yeah that's that
laid-back california rock instead of
like
you know like the more political
hard-driving
relevant southern fried rock that creeks
was doing
fair enough fair enough it's like don
henley always kind of like it's not i'm
not a knock
there are some great don nedley songs
but it's always like you could always
see how people would be like i don't
know about this guy
yeah no the the only eagle song i like
is um
what are these nights
the other ones i find very skippable uh
anyways
um i guess let's finish this trailer man
high crimes
and bliss demeanors
the coen brothers killed steve you semi
and miller's crossing cut him down to
just a leg in fargo
and turned him into ash and lebowski
that dude is so getting vaped in the
next movie
like a tradition it's uh it's putting
them in smaller and smaller
uh containers containers
uh anywho um you guys have any
any final thoughts on those two films or
lebowski in general
i love the big lebowski it's like
infinitely rewatchable like i've seen it
hundreds of times and i could still
throw it on and it would be fun
to watch yeah yeah it's both a fun movie
to watch with the crowd and also the
kind of fun movie that you can clean
your apartment with and like those i
find are really rare because
and maybe just because i know it um but
yeah it's really easy entertainment and
if you put it on in a party your party
is over and now your party is just
watching big lebowski
it's also that one has a great
soundtrack that is songs i did not know
before they were in
this movie especially the kenny rogers
uh
just stepped in to see what condition my
condition was in
the plays during the dream sequence
amazing amazing soundtrack
um i wonder why like this one has popped
so much more had such a cult life like
there aren't festivals around like lou
and davis or whatever
but probably because of like the
contemporary setting and i think like we
were talking earlier
all their movies are a little bit about
how life is meaningless but this one
or or how it's random and and
unconnected but this one is like more of
an upbeat
take on that right yeah i mean i do
think that philosophically the movie has
something to say that is like a nice
thing like i think the
the dude abides has like staying power
as a as a life philosophy i feel like
that feels relevant for people in a way
that goes beyond just the movie and
effort let's go bowling
yeah although is there a commentary
about how like because he's like a he
was a 60s radical who was like
engaged and now he just is parroting you
know george
bush and like he's just totally checked
out and like has has
completely lost his involvement in the
world is it supposed maybe
darker than than we're giving a credit
it's not as dark as chicago seven ending
and letting you know that uh the guy
became a stockbroker
oh by the way jerry reuben became a
stockbroker like what so the film is
meaningless is what you're saying like
nothing matters just uh it's all just a
game
where they're all just showing up to
play i i
what what just don't tell me that i just
don't even want to know that
get out sorkin let me let me just work
and that's like a happy ending though um
like oh good he cleaned up and made
something of himself remember that guy
that i pretended caught an egg
stock broken out effort let's go bowling
uh
might as well yeah it's a sunnier let's
see what uh let's see what we cut out of
this
this masterpiece so it's like the exact
same plot as joker
with more caesar romero
[Music]
up donny vibes the [ __ ] up donny he just
wants to bowl man lay off him
[Music]
i think he's just jealous man cause
donnie is clearly the best bowler
he always pulls strikes historian the
big
chill citizen dank jeff daniels
the dude okay boomer a stranger in the
alps
the vet offensive donny in the darko
alfred not even pennyworth feminist
fatale
killed a wabbit love and other rugs
hey did you know the night donnie dies
his bowling shirt says johnson on it and
earlier in the movie the nihilists who
kill him threatened to cut off the dudes
johnson
now that was something i read on like an
imdb fact that turned out to not be true
so
don't trust your your user submitted
imdb
facts i was like oh wow someone noticed
this crazy detail
sure um think before you write your own
trust but verify
phone yeah trust me that's the lesson
here exactly
um thank you guys so much to uh for
watching this point uh please subscribe
on the off chance that you haven't and
hit the like and hit the bell so you
never
miss another thing um and then you can
uh well you don't have to subscribe to
do this but you can send chat
questions to the ama and we'll answer
them right here live on the show
um evan j pretzel writes it's your boy
evan j pretzel
welcome back wow he he submitted like
five questions and i'm not gonna let you
dominate this show mr j
pretzel um but let's let's pick one here
um
okay what would the group's 30s nickname
be a la hot fingers pirelli
oh like go around and pick our pick our
30s nicknames
i mean you're definitely lime ricky yeah
i'll i'll take that i'll accept that one
yeah
um i don't know uh uh
boogaloo rad something like that i'm
trying to think of like 30s words
it was a different time in a different
language so something like that right
um yeah yeah that that works uh i was
thinking um
these are the kind of thoughts that i
usually keep to myself but it's but it's
today
uh where i was thinking how funny it
would be to have like a
a very italian cowboy so
like hey i mean
every spaghetti western is what you're
describing yeah
i'm thinking like more like jersey like
sopranos like that kind of cowboy
like christopher multisand because we're
multicellular like i'm rope in here
it's my first rodeo what are you gonna
do you're not gonna
round up that cattle you stood not see i
like the idea of being like an italian
like oh i put on the horseshoe you know
so i guess i'll be um but i definitely
recommend the cinema of sergio leone if
italians pretending to be cowboys is
something that intrigues you
i'll be the calzone cowboy that'll be my
that'll be my nickname
um wow that doesn't sound like a 30s
nickname
like let's be honest you would get a
nickname i would be like
lonnie the jew like
it would not be a clever and i would do
like people did back then where they
just pretended they were italians like
oh no my dark skin
i'm just yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah the
[Laughter]
sicilian
uh okay one more evan because you you
you submitted uh uh like ten
so here's uh we'll give you two for ten
um jeff bridges wore his own clothes in
the movie
uh mostly what movie's made better by an
actor dressing themselves for it or
maybe what movie would be made better by
an actor
wearing their own wardrobe um on film
batman89 i think if you just get
uh if you just get him batman like
wearing his own
hanging out every day 80s shirts i think
90 shows that would be red
also nicholson just didn't like his
laker laker game
you know regular outfit yeah yeah
that that that would be good i think
jonah hill could could pull off some
some outfits but he's not in in like
anything serious enough where that would
like really pop
like i feel like he could wear all of
his his like street wear
in you know super bad or 21 jump street
and it looked fine but
i'd just like to see more of his clothes
i feel like nicolas cage
characters often dress more normally
than just
nicholas cage like when you see nicholas
cage in the world
he's always got some like crazy jacket
on it's
like wild prince stuff and it's just
like him doing like a drama like
joe but he's just dressed like everyday
nicholas cage i think would be a lot of
fun
yeah yeah right he has the the voodoo
skull sewn into his uh
jacket lining for ghost rider yeah like
honestly like castor troy
is probably his character with the most
in common with his real
fashion sets which is amazing to think
about
so good uh if he carried like gold
guns with dragons on them i would not be
surprised if you're like no no that's
just those were nicholas cage guns
no they're not props be careful with
that just work them into the movie yeah
uh and lovetto writes uh was the audio
chip eating recorded for this trailer or
do i just carry it around on my phone no
that was custom that was custom
uh also what is the best flavor of
potato chips
salt and vinegar anyone oh that's me
salt and vinegar
that's like punishment i don't i don't i
really don't understand
salt and vinegar chips well you're
outvoted i got
i love salt and vinegar chips i need to
pair them with like i have to drink beer
or something similar at the same time
like you can't just have that without
a beverage uh whereas i could eat like
doritos
you know all day every day but yeah salt
and vinegar great pick great picks
sour cream and onion king of chip
flavors i got
i'm just gonna come out here and say
like barbecue pretty good but
sour cream and onion uh number one with
a bullet
they were my gateway to salt and vinegar
actually there you go
how about those maui onion chips those
are funny oh i like those little sweet
little salty
also uh there is a what are those like
those kettle chips
there's one of those that's like thai
spice or something that's like got a
like a little bit of a thai
peppery flavor that's really really good
i got some
some pickle flavored chips at trader
joe's yesterday i'm i'm
excited slash concerned uh but i have to
try i'll try anything once
and that's uh it sounded intriguing so
i'll report back with how that is
and you can expect more exciting content
like this on share those commentaries
when we come back next week for um
uh yeah because we're we're still
figuring it out oh okay good i was like
did i forget to do my work
i haven't fully uh fully committed one
way or the other uh because
nothing's coming out this week there's
like literally nothing to tie it into
so just look at some requests done the
mortal kombat
films before everybody freaks out
there's nothing coming out this week we
know that we're looking
at that but we've done that's true
that's that's a good point um
to point that out before everybody in
the comments is like what the hell are
you talking about finish him yeah so we
there will be some mortal kombat in the
future don't worry um
i'm sure you can predict some other
things that may be ending or releasing
soon
that we'll also be covering but next
week it's a wild card that's what we're
all about
wild card um i hope everybody has a
safe and happy earth day uh thank you
danielle
thank you alan for joining me i'll get
back to you about those pickle chips and
we'll see you next week
[Music]
you